advertisement to play real quick and then we'll get started
so it'll be
you notice something a little different about me i mean i
have been hitting the gym a little bit more recently let me
just give a little
man it feels so good to do this and i wouldn't be able to do
it without today's sponsor live 2d inc using their official
VTuber app, Nizima Live!
With Nizima Live, you can realize your virtual anime dreams
with their easy-to-use VTuber tracking app.
Their app tracks your facial expressions, has fun item
presets, super fun special effects, all within the
easy-to-use app.
And even if you don't have a model yet, you can try out the
preset models within the app right now.
Visit the Nizima Live official website to download a free
trial.
And once you're hooked, you can use this coupon code on your
subscription.
description!
Well, are you ready to start your journey?
Become a VTuber right now!
Nizima Live is here to help make it happen!
My, my, boo!
Hello, everybody!
I just been chain-smoking, like, crazy.
I had to, I was, like, tapped out and All I could hear was,
ah, ah, ah, ah, ah.
Zach, thank you so much for the super time.
I won't be able to catch the tail end of today because I'll
be going to see a movie, have fun.
Have fun,
have fun.
Why?
I just had, oh my God, I just felt something in my teeth.
And you know, when you sometimes you're like, oh, I just, I
just ate, right?
And I was like, oh, there's something in my teeth.
And then I was like, okay, well, I'll chew it.
And then you chew it, and it's like a thing of pepper.
And now I'm like...
Ah,
ah, ah, ah, ah, ah!
Ah!
Game is louder than me.
I just turned it down.
Uh, I think I'm...
It's quiet because I'm facing away from my mic because I'm
looking at stuff.
I just, I, uh, I redid some things on my computer, so some
of my settings are a little off.
So I'm like, wait a second.
Now everything feels a little strange.
Everything feels a little...
Like, like some stuff has moved two centimeters.
That's not right.
That can't, that can't be there.
Made it to a live stream at work.
Good luck with the work, Elaine!
Good... I said work and luck at the same time.
Good work.
Hello, me, Tom, and I was like, yo!
Just got off work today, Otsu!
And they were trying to dunk me in paint.
Or something.
It was rough.
Why are they trying to dunk you in paint?
What is that?
Is that like a swirly bite?
A paintly?
Hmm.
Glossed pepper.
No, not even.
Many be smoking as much as snake on the MGS4 loading screen.
I'm telling you, this guy is super like...
It was a long day.
But yeah.
Welcome back to Grim Vandango.
We're back here.
We're back.
We're on year three.
It has been two years.
Wait, we've skipped one year.
gone another year so it has been two years right since we
lost that lady and i'm scared there's a really cute ghost on
screen that's a skeleton you silly that's a skeleton but be
quick thank you so much for the gift thank you chain smoker
manny my guy is stressed my man is stressed right now
because we last time got a call that we were rather we were
about to dock at this port and have Draco thank you we were
about to dock at this port and then we got a call saying
don't dock at the port because they're coming on to your
ship and they're gonna they're gonna get you get you get you
one way or another they're gonna get you they're gonna get
you get you get you one way or another they're gonna get
yeah call from a pigeon the pigeon was yeah i forgot it was
a pigeon i i forgot that that was a pigeon one way or
another i'm gonna find you i'm gonna get to get to get to
get to get to one way or another i'm gonna get you i'm gonna
get to get to get to get you Chapter was the last one I
played before I never picked it up.
Well, let's beat the game together, huh?
Shall we?
Manny, Manny, chill, chill, chill, buddy.
Chill, chill, chill, chill.
What's in here?
Oh!
That's really bad.
Wait.
Wait, that's like really bad.
My men?
Wait, are you okay?
I'm sorry I led you into trouble, Zaylor.
Ensign Arnold was just a kid.
Ensign Arnold!
I'm not gonna disrupt the evidence.
Oh, okay.
Sure, sure, sure.
Oh, no, indeed.
Oh, no, no, no.
We were smoking for way too long, I think.
Oh, my gosh.
This can't be happening.
happening.
Hey, he's back here.
Sack him.
Oh my god.
Custom officials, open this door.
Yeah, we want to check your bags.
Don't worry, Captain.
We're safe in here.
Okay, let's just set the explosives and get the hell out of
here.
Oh my gosh, good news.
It's Tuesday, should be available for purchase.
Thank goodness!
Glottis!
Glottis, what's happening?
I mean, we know what's happening.
It's just, wait, why can't I click on him, but I can.
It's kinda strange, right?
Glottis, what do these readouts mean?
That we're gonna blow up, Captain!
And it's gonna hurt!
That's the throttle for the port side engine.
Not picking that up.
Use it?
Oh, shoot.
I'm just about to do stuff.
I guess we'll do it.
Look at, he has little ears.
He's shivering.
Throttle.
No matter what I do, nothing changes.
Oh.
All right.
What else we got here?
Can I get off?
No!
Wait, I didn't mean to do that.
Mani Amito!
Hello again, thank you so much for the super time!
Blam, fun fact, Grim Pandango has been in multiple museums
over the years as an example of a true video game work of
art.
Seriously?
Wait, that's awesome.
The anchor, yeah, I can't, oh, you was the exit.
I was trying to figure out how to get off of this thing.
What's this thing do?
That's the port anchor control.
Oh, maybe we press that?
It's attached pretty well.
Oh, we'll press it.
okay what is this no rush manny no rush no no need to run
does the starboard anchor control wait port i don't know the
difference between equally gladys sure did a number on that
old diesel if it were just a little more powerful we could
probably tear on out of here what do you mean more powerful
it's not powerful enough hey maintain say that is left
starboard is right oh thank you Well, then we need to do
both, no, because it looked like both anchors were down
before.
Oh, okay.
Sure.
And look, what about this side?
All right.
Both are good, right?
Full speed ahead?
Put the anchors in your pocket.
Wait, why are we still not?
moving or doing anything this one stopped no oh oh wait are
we like trapped in oh wait oh i think i just realized what
wait reverse
reverse reverse reverse but your dog we don't have to be we
can we can ram into something.
Or we can.
Chachavro smooth.
Now I think we're back where we were.
Yeah, yeah.
I think I don't know how to drive a boat.
I think.
Why can't I talk to you?
Gladys, why won't you talk to me?
we need to put one down.
So if I can go...
Okay, hold on.
Push this one, we'll try it.
Use your dredge experience.
Yeah.
Which way was it that worked?
Was it this one?
No.
Oh, yes.
Okay.
I dragged the anchor a little bit.
have you tried pressing the use key while manny is looking
at glottis a use key what key is that i i point and click on
everything only thing missing is minto in a sailor uniform
i don't know i'm just i'm i don't know what the order of
operations here is but we're just doing anything we can
actually wait oh try wait lift it up and then go over here
what if we do something with this while it's like pulled
wait did it just not do anything oh oh look at that they're
kissing i don't know what that does though uh so wait so
this one is like pulled Underneath like that.
I have no idea what I'm doing, though.
I have no idea what I'm supposed to do from here, though.
What if our anchors touched?
Kyo!
Soft survey.
Thank you for the peek.
It was so fun meeting your AX.
I was with my boyfriend!
Yes!
I looked up the sweets maze on afterwards.
I thank you so much I'm gonna get some stuff and we'll match
smells I'm so excited to see you your new outfit for legends
and new thank you for coming to see us you guys were so cute
yeah thank you thank you I'm on the right track I feel like
I am otherwise this wouldn't be a thing right or something
who knows
matching scents.
Okay, yeah, we have a little necklace on.
But what does that do?
We're back here, though.
And now we're back to where we were before.
Reverse, reverse.
Forward?
Full speed.
ahead.
Sigma, thank you for 15 months.
Thank you, thank you.
Let's go back to this spot, I suppose.
Did your inventory change?
Oh, I haven't checked here.
I haven't checked.
But forward.
What does having both anchors like this me
it just it lingers on that screen like look do you see it
now that's what you're supposed to do oh yeah
see the boat hello
okay Do you not understand the puzzle?
No rush, though.
Not like we're going to explode or anything.
What if?
Arimito just wanted to say thanks for making us all spoiled.
Bye, thank you.
Thanks, Hungry Board.
The solution is incredibly stupid.
Is it?
I think the situation...
is that the front of the boat is tethered to the port so you
can't just back away we're smoking oh stop man you have a
problem that would make sense okay they don't really like
explain that at all do they they're just kind of like by the
way by the way your boat can't move for some reason for some
reason though i really can't it shows me that i can click on
glottis let me Oh, I pressed the use button.
Oh no, did that just...
I hope that didn't just reset it.
I pressed the use button while looking at GLaDOS.
Oh no.
Let's see.
Oh no!
I think they're...
Let me do...
Let me...
Oh wait, how do I check my items again?
Oh, here we go.
my side and that's it baby divorce no no no it's too early
okay it was a temporary setback it was a temporary they went
to couples therapy or something It's fine.
But if I...
Wait, maybe I do this again.
Whoops, no.
Is it on that side now?
Yes.
You're late because you were watching the Kachok capsule
mod.
Thank you for watching the mod.
You didn't miss much at all.
I bet this is the first puzzle, baby.
Wait, I'm piloting it from over here.
Uh-oh.
Wait, the game is broken.
Let's do it from here.
Let's do it properly.
Like, what does this do for me?
Props to the devs for these puzzles really get you thinking.
For real, though.
For real.
Is there anything else in this room that I missed?
We have two buttons.
Gladys, what do these readouts mean?
They were gonna blow up, Captain.
And it's gonna hurt.
I wonder.
What if I like stick my scythe through or something?
You know?
Oh, I wonder.
It would probably be easier to raise your hand.
Why'd you put it away?
Wait, that's not what...
That's not what I told you to do.
You wink it.
Or something.
Okay, he's coming up with an idea.
Well, there you go.
Okay.
Steiner wants to know any booths that will have Steiner
merch and wants to make a map to specifically upset you.
Do what you want with this info.
I don't think this guy realizes that like, we hired him.
Which means you can do the opposite of hiring.
If need be.
really need to put this guy in his place anyway oh it's
broken again okay so now wait let's I don't want to like
pilot it from over here and accidentally cause something in
the game Mito smarto smarto let's see let's see wait did I
need to have done it from the oh wait wait
hold on
unless what if I since this is now in what i tried to do
before was when i tried to pull it i tried to have it like
yank to the other side now oh oh wait i think i need to be
closer though right what was that the dotted line buddy
now we need to be to the dock right okay no stop it please
okay you know what fine wait which one was that I didn't
turn it the right way that should move it close to the dock
right yeah now we should be able to disembark I'm a
telepathic obviously can we leave Can't reach.
Oh, good thing I have a...
A side.
Can we leave?
If I mess with these anchors anymore, we might go down with
the ship.
Aren't we trying to get off, though?
Oh, yeah, probably Gladys can't fit through, huh?
Wait, what's this side look like?
we're getting somewhere there has been progress made just
Wow counselor thank you so much for the I miss seeing the
Rubikava stream live there's plenty there's there's plenty
of content there I always get excited when you dip into
these adventure games I like the Nancy Drew streams from
last year I want to play more Nancy Drew thank you so much
for that Kassupo thank you so much thank you thank you what
do you think Manny meant by the dotted line kind of ominous
that's how I feel
like he said I don't need to mess with these anymore right
oh if I mess with these anchors anymore we might go down
with the ship does it anyway that's fine
oh here we go the dotted line is us leaving
Dang, if only we had gotten to that other half of this ship
20 minutes ago.
What did that say?
I don't know.
Oh, I was getting...
Oh, no!
We're sleeping with the fishers!
I'm not playing that later this week!
Oh, no!
Oh, oh, oh, seven.
Lola.
No, my ship.
Oh, 7.
Oh.
Mally, choking.
Meada.
Snap out of it, Sailor.
Easy for you to say.
You don't have lungs.
Hey, you live without your heart once, so you can live
without air for a little while.
Just until I figure out what we're gonna do.
Whatever Glottis' voice actor got paid, it was not enough.
Whatever Gladys' voice actor got paid, it was not enough.
We're just casually walking on the floor.
Beware, brave captain.
Here in the darkest depths of the sea of lament, dwell the
most horrible monsters of all.
The fearsome, murky demons of the deep will swallow you
whole the instant you leave this pool of light.
One step forward and learn for yourself.
All right, all right.
I believe you just quit it with the creepy stare of the land
voice, huh?
Burger or hot dog?
Here comes one now.
Typically hot dog.
I mean, burger.
What's happening?
Oh, wow.
Look at that thing.
Look at him truplotting along.
Let's go, mister.
Oh, was I supposed to do something with him?
Okay, that might not have been a sea monster, but it was
pretty safe.
spooky according to our map i think that's the pearl i
definitely go over there first chance i get but there's a
lot of dark water between here and there uh oh well that guy
he's he can't he's all the way over there we can ask him for
help once he comes back you all right i'm a spirit of the
land manny not of the sea hang in there mano
From Spongebob.
Oh, he's so far away!
So we have to speak like this.
Looks like I let you down again.
Oh, I think her days of use are over.
I told you that name was Bad Luck.
Hey, sorry.
We're underwater.
We're not on the moon.
There he is.
We're waiting for him to come back.
Can I take this light?
Oh, Lola.
Oh, no.
Looks like I let you...
Oh, I think her days of use are over.
Oh, you think I hear him?
No, I don't.
Where'd he go?
Where'd that guy go?
Is Manny gonna smoke down here?
That'd be pretty funny.
Oh!
Hello!
Amigo!
Huh?
Who?
Oh, geez, another secret!
You see?
That's why I'll never travel by boat.
What are you doing down here?
Trying to get out of the land of the dead, same as everybody
else.
Is everything okay with your eyebrows?
What's wrong with his eyebrows?
Them is barnacles, genius.
I don't move fast enough to shake them, so they tend to pile
up.
Barnacles are disgusting.
Ain't you boys?
Barnacles are so sickening.
They disgust me.
I hate barnacles.
Barnacles are so gross and terrible.
Charles Darwin agrees.
They're so...
Yeah, they're hard.
They're difficult to remove.
Your uncle was a barnacle?
Yeah, barnacle head.
That's what he was.
Sorry, I'm too your uncle.
I don't, yeah, I'm sorry, I didn't know your, I don't know
your uncle, I'm sorry.
Speaking from experience, yes!
They are, no wonder they're a swear in SpongeBob.
They're just so bad, and like, they're gross, and they get
everywhere, and if you step on them, it's like stepping on a
Lego with a, so, a load of barnacles, it is.
Barnacles are terrible.
Do you think barnacles are cute?
A barnacle could be watching this stream.
Barnacle hater, barnacle, barnacle hater.
The only good barnacle is a dead barnacle.
And the one's getting cleaned off lobsters.
Yeah!
They like stick to toidles and things.
And they are so sad.
The guys that get stuck upon, they're like, Oh no, I got
barnacles on me.
It's so sad.
They stick to everything.
This is how we find out 25% of Mito's viewers are barnacles.
Yeah, they stick to whales.
Oh god, they're so bad.
Acne of the sea.
Have you seen the lobster fishermen that cleans barnacles
off of lobsters and then lets the lobster go with this snack
oh I think I have actually yes I have actually I do know
what you're talking about because he like puts the snack in
their hands their claws barnacles are considered a delicacy
in Japan what am I supposed to be like oh I'm not sure I'm
not sure I'm not sure I don't know
I'm never heard.
Can you even eat barnacles?
If you try hard enough.
They're just like any other shellfish.
You like suck them out.
Like a...
It's really freaky when they get water on them.
Like, you know, you'll see them on the land and they get
water on them.
And you see their tiny little teeth in this inside being
like...
Blah, blah, blah, whee!
Barnacles hate.
Anyway.
I feel bad for this guy.
Some barnacles species are edible, but most are too tiny.
Taisen, welcome to membership.
I hope I said your name right.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
Moshkaste, obsessed with the barnacles this car.
So nice.
Let's ask, why are you walking why are you walking instead
of taking a ship got sick of waiting around rubikava for a
boat figured it'd make better time this way you're going in
circles my man amigo you're going in circles how do you know
where you're going see the moon over there i just keep it on
my right that way i know i'm heading in a straight line but
oldest trick in the book oh oh no but the moon
Uh-oh.
How long have you been down here?
Well, let me put it this way.
I wasn't always this color.
Blue?
He could have been blue.
Dabade, dabade, dabade, die.
Dabade, dabade, dabade, dead because he's a skelly.
Let's see.
How have you kept that light going all these years?
Well, I found this coral.
the dark coral.
What?
Dangerous thing.
Glows like a lightning bug and it never seems to wear out.
I had some of that once.
Made a nice grappling hook.
I don't think you had what I got because I don't think
you've been to the place where I got it.
Na, na, na, na, na.
You haven't been there and I have.
You don't have my coral.
You're a big liar.
Na, na, na, na, na, na.
Why would you think that you're a big dummy?
You don't have my coral because only I've been there and No
one else in the world.
Coral gatekeeper.
So where'd you get the coral?
Where'd you get the coral?
Edge of the world, boy.
That's the only place it grows.
Edge of the...
Minecraft?
Coral-less behavior.
Um...
Shouldn't you have hit dry land by now?
I'm trying to cross a big ocean here, Sonny.
What are you saying about it?
I've already done it.
In a boat.
A boat?
Don't talk to me about boats.
is just what's the problem with boats we had such a nice
boat nice boat always talking about boats you got a
perfectly good pair of legs why not use them i say what is a
cortisol i've heard that low cortisol and high cortisol what
does that mean what i oh chat chat chat reddit help me
What does it mean?
Cortisol is stress.
Oh, it's a stress hormone.
Oh, brain chemicals.
You guys are thinking.
Low cortisol is win-mintho.
So that's bad?
Wait.
So, wait.
Cortisol is a stress response hormone.
More cortisol in your blood equals more stress.
Do you really gotta call this Reddit?
What else should I call you?
There's like a Reddit thread for anything that you ever
Google if you have a problem.
I just Google my problem, and then a Reddit thread comes up,
and like, 80% of the time it will solve my problem.
Yeah, ask Ibu, ask Jeeves.
Yahoo answers, ibu, ibu answers, ibu answers, ibu answers.
Yeah, cortisone is what I was thinking of.
I was like, so cortisol, I was thinking of the anti-itch
cream.
When Minto dances, I get low cortisol.
It just makes me, it just makes it sound like a bad thing.
If you have higher of anything is a good thing, though.
High golf score.
Hi.
Blood pressure.
Nice boat helps prevent the cortisol spikes.
So, cortisone.
Not everybody was getting itchy.
Got it.
Thank you.
High barnacle levels is a good thing.
Not all high.
High stuff is a good thing.
Okay, I've learned my lesson now.
Everybody keep your cortisone levels low, low, low.
You cannot be stressed.
You have to have...
You cannot be itchy and you cannot be stressed.
And you must keep them low, low, low.
So you can...
What does it do?
Wait, what?
I guess it's just good to not be stressed.
But if you have a high cortisone, Cortis- Cortis- Cortis-
Cortis- Cortis-S- Cortis-Sol.
Cortis-Sol- Cortis-Cortisol.
Cortis-Cortis-Cortisol.
If you have the high levels, what does it do to you?
You need to chillax.
You should ask me questions instead for real.
I don't misinform.
I just lie.
It stresses you out.
Don't be stressed!
Don't be stressed.
If the itching makes you stressed, then you take a cortisol
and your cortisol will go down.
Don't be stressed.
Stop your stress right now.
Stop it.
Lower your cortisol levels.
Listen to the sound of my voice and I can see the levels
dropping.
One percentage at a time.
Two!
Oh my gosh, it's dropping exponentially.
Essentially, you are no longer stressed.
You are free.
You are free of any stress in your life.
You did it.
All the barnacle talk got me stressed.
No, no, no.
That's barnacles.
That's a load of barnacles.
And don't even think about a load of barnacles because those
guys suck and they're scary.
Just don't be stressed.
If you think about cortisol, think about your favorite food
and eat it.
And your cortisol will go down.
I'm feeling stressed about keeping my cortisol levels low.
What should I do?
They are lowest.
They're the lowest they'll ever...
They are the lowest that anyone could ever get them ever.
If you've got stress, stop it.
Get some help.
All right, let's keep going.
Let me guess.
You died in a boat wreck.
A boat wreck would have been better than what happened to
us.
Led off course by bad equipment.
Lost for weeks.
No food.
No shelter from the sun.
We started throwing the dead overboard.
Wait, why didn't you eat them?
Then the sharks began following the boat.
Did you get eaten?
What happened in the end?
What happened was I learned three valuable things.
lessons stay away from boats when it comes to navigation
trust only the moon and the stars and when there's only two
of you left never ever go to sleep I think somebody got
eaten we've had a little accident I think you could help us
out depends on what kind of help you're looking for um could
you take us to the pearl take us to the pearl 44 minutes
nice-paced cannibalism ghost thank you gigantic pearl that
shines so brightly it can be seen from passing ships and
they sometimes sailors so are lured by its luster actually
fling themselves overboard to dive for it and are never
heard from again yeah and I think it's right over blah I've
been lost in this ocean for years I ain't never seen it no
really yeah it's right over there.
No, really.
The pearl is right over there.
You poor sucker.
That's the moon.
Tell me you didn't come all this way out here to pearl dive
the moon.
The moon is in the ocean?
Could we borrow that light for a second?
Sorry, I'm kind of attached to it.
I get it.
Well, then... Could we tag along with you?
Well, it's a long walk you're talking about.
He does go over there.
Oh, all right, then.
Lift those knees.
Stick close to my light and try to sing in key.
We're singing?
It's a mine.
I'm gonna let it shine.
This little light of mine.
No, he's rushing it a little bit.
I'm gonna let it shine.
Let it shine.
Let it under some seaweed.
No.
I'm gonna let it shine.
Let it shine.
I'm gonna let it shine!
It's just chaos!
Supermoons and monsters!
Yeah, I'm gonna let it shine!
Let it shine!
I'm not gonna let you touch it!
No!
I'm gonna let it shine!
I'm not gonna let you touch it!
No!
I'm gonna let it shine!
I'm not gonna let you touch it!
No!
I'm gonna let it shine!
Let it shine!
Oh, oops, I interrupted him because I tried to click on
that.
Is that not it right there?
It won't let me do anything.
I think they stopped singing.
They stopped talking.
Uh-oh.
We're gone.
Oh, I'm so scared!
For a second!
We were gone and the game glitched!
I thought that looked like our ship That's just a trick the
ocean plays on your mind, kid.
Makes everything look the same after a while, like he was
going in circles.
Well, this isn't the kind of progress I was hoping for.
Oh, well, the wet march of the soul ain't for everybody.
Yeah, let's, uh...
Could you send for help?
Oh, sure.
I promised to call for help at the next phone booth I walked
by.
Well, I don't want to break your stride there.
Okay, see you around.
Watch out for sea monsters.
Wait, what guys?
Whoa!
Oh, they don't miss with old Chepito.
I'm too bright for them.
This little light of mine, I'm gonna let it shine.
This little light of mine.
He's just standing there.
Shine, let it shine, let it shine, let it shine.
I eat it under some seaweed.
No, I'm gonna let it shine.
Just pick him up, GLaDOS!
Let go!
Get your own lamp, pal!
Whatever happened to the coat of the sea!
They make your cortisol spike, but thankfully we're okay.
Let it shine.
Uh, wait, save Gim?
What do we do now?
I'm a spirit of the land, Manny.
See?
Hang in there, mano.
Is that the pearl?
What is the pearl?
According to our map, I think that's the pearl.
I definitely go over there first chance I get, but there's a
lot of dark water between here and there.
I think I have to wait for him to come back, though, no?
Uh...
I have to wait for him to come back.
This little light up's mine.
I'm gonna let it shine.
This little light up mine there is.
I thought that we would like lead him over here, you know?
I'd definitely go over there first chance I'd get, but
there's a lot of dark Yeah, we gotta snatch him up.
Glottis, we need your big, burly arms to get, to grab this
little guy.
And take him over to the pearl.
Snatch him up.
Yeah, we'll save when he comes back over here, so that we
can, if we mess up, we don't have to wait for him to you
doing that?
How are you doing that?
Street reminds me of Freddy Fish.
Have you played?
I have.
Well, I've only played one Freddy Fish.
It was the haunting schoolhouse, or the haunted schoolhouse.
It was the only one I cared about because it was about a
haunting.
Save.
You'll find that...
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Amigo!
Hey, I'm talking to you.
He kept walking.
He kept walking while I was saving the game.
Wait, if I load the game.
He looks like he's been down here a long time.
Oh my god.
Bro sped up, I swear.
What?
It's not a pause screen.
Oh my god.
okay but um you'll when i even when i was like a wee wee
ghost i would play things and watch things only because like
they were ghostly related like the haunted i spy and haunted
school house um i was i was like i didn't play any other i
spy game i didn't care play any other Freddy fish game.
I didn't care.
Okay, wait, I'm going to save here.
Okay, this should be good.
This should be good.
Okay, he's coming.
He's right here.
I'm going to get a sip.
Man, he's stop.
Stop smoking underwater.
That makes no sense.
Glottis, where are you looking, buddy?
Come on.
Okay, that took way longer.
What?
More survivors?
I just passed another shipwreck not five minutes ago.
Well, I don't want to break your stride there.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, grab him, grab him!
This little light of mine, I'm gonna let it shine.
Hey, Leo!
Can I use mine?
Lego, Lego, Lego!
Do I need my scythe or something there?
I wonder.
People have been trying to steal my lap all day!
Whatever happened to the code of the...
My scythe.
I like to keep it next to where my heart used to be.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
A sequence broke a little.
Oh, geez.
Wait.
Guys, I broke the game.
Oh, my game just crashed.
My bad.
It's okay.
We saved.
Yeah, it's a good thing we saved.
Okay.
Wait, let me...
Maybe I can get it out early.
We just have to wait like a few.
That soul has already been reaped.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Oh, gosh, you're so slow!
Why?
Okay, load game.
Maybe you can click on Glottis while he's struggling.
We can try.
Oh
This little light of mine, I'm gonna let it shine Hey,
buddy, amigo.
What more soon?
Hey, well, okay.
This little light of mine.
I'm gonna let it shine This little light of mine.
I'm gonna let it shine.
Do the thing.
Oh, we did What am I supposed to do with this?
Follow me.
Where are you?
Yeah, just pick him up.
Just pick him up Nice.
Oh, the caboose.
Wow.
Danny, is that the pearl?
Holy!
Do I fight her someday?
I am rich, rich, rich, rich, rich.
Are you rich?
Something's happening.
Danny, what's going on?
Whoa, what's happening?
The scream was legit.
I don't know.
know, but I don't like the way that thing's looking at us.
Oh, he's looking.
Okay, hold on.
Save the game.
Okay.
I'm not going down there while I'm... I think we found our
transportation.
Thank you for the...
Read the rank.
Thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
Hey, Chippido, go for a swim, will you?
You're drawing too much attention to us.
Too bad.
I'm sticking to you like the particles on my So don't even
think you're sneaking up with my bro.
Glorious.
Go down there and talk demon talk to that octopus.
Heck no, I'm scared.
I'm staying up here with you.
So there really is a pearl.
But does that mean Misha really jumped overboard here?
It all just seems so fishy.
Fishy.
Strike!
Thank you so much for the thank you too.
I've got more important things on my mind.
Thank you.
Not me.
Can I talk then?
Oh, okay.
Sorry, sorry.
Goodness.
What's over here?
Oh, he's looking at us.
He's looking at us still.
What's this?
What are these?
Oh, he's looking at us, he's looking at us still.
Not quite as famous as the pearl is the slimy
barnacle-covered old rock of legend.
Ew.
Wait, those are barnacles in the water?
I don't want to get tangled up in those.
Then I'll cut them.
Nobody wants them.
Slip just...
What?
Come on.
Disgusting.
My cortisol is so high right now.
No, don't let it be.
Don't let it be.
We're just going down.
Oh, they're stuck to him.
Uh, you good?
Hey, Leo.
Hey, where are you going?
Oh, he's looking at the light.
You can't leave here all alone.
Come back here.
Are we sacrificing this guy?
Oh, my God.
Oh, what's happening?
what okay at least we get a ride right looks like we're
heading south wait what about the pearl that edge of the
world except the edge of the world oh legitimately where
does i get
what is going on here
Don't ask, Carnal, because I don't know.
What the heck?
It won't let me do anything.
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
Oh.
See any hint of that octopus swimming around here?
No, but I can smell them.
What's over here?
Before we go that way?
Is there this way?
No.
Oh, it's so...
It's so ominous.
Oh wait, I could just do that.
Oh!
Wait!
What is this?
Is it not transporting us over there?
Okay, strange.
Maybe that pole reverses it.
But before we do that, let's go to here.
What was that?
Man, he's just like, see ya.
I'm gonna sneak inside and look for Mechi.
What if that octopus comes back while you're gone?
Poke him in the eye and steal his sub.
Hey, stupid octopus.
So true.
What if...
Is the octopus like stealing skellies and enslaving them?
Is this Indiana Jones?
The children?
They're all getting enslaved in the caves?
Hmm.
This door's locked.
Okay.
Where are we?
I think you can ride it up.
Okay, well.
We'll try again after...
I want to look around first, obviously.
Meche?
Meche.
Manny, what are you doing here?
I wanted to see how your trip was going, Angel.
I am your travel agent, you know.
By the way, thanks for that bottle of champagne you sent me.
It really hit the spot.
You were headed for a trap.
I was trying to warn you.
Domino was using me like bait.
I didn't want you to end up a prisoner here like me.
Prisoner?
Where's your cell?
Or are you just sharing a bomb?
with a warden oh if that's what you think of me then why did
you come here because this is where he belongs here working
for me i knew you'd come around eventually right or wrong
manuel calavera is always with the winning team right manny
that's why you're here now i'm getting off this rock and i'm
taking all of these people with me domino what is this manny
there's no way off this island I'm afraid you're stuck here
in my little executive training program.
See, I need you to take my place here, kid I've got to get
back to the city where the action is Sorry, man, I had to
come in my skin was getting all pruny Him I don't need don't
you dare
I'm gonna grind you to powder for that Gauron Maybe later,
but for now, let me just show you your new office a jail
cell careful bb the new boss is waking up where that voice
sounds so familiar glottis glottis can swim upright right
right what am i saying i'm speaking i'm They took my tongue!
Wait, I had no tongue.
Oh, they took my voice box!
It's Bobby!
Yeah, I think it's Bobby.
Hola, Angelitos.
I'll bite you, I swear to God!
Please don't bite anyone else, Pugsy.
That's why they put us in the cage in the first place.
Why is this so creepy?
Why do you want to bite me?
You're the mean new boss.
Mr. Hurley said you were meaner than him.
He said you had a bone saw.
Is it actually...
Wait.
Have you watched Recess or Big Guy and Rusty?
Also, yeah.
Wait, Recess?
Oh, wait.
I have watched Recess.
Who?
Who in Recess?
Spinelli It's actually the lady who voices Bobby Hill That's
so funny I loved Spinelli She was so cute She was like my
inspo That was that point right My name is Manny Calavera
What's yours?
Mr. Harley told us about you They're so loud though Tricked
Meche Poor Meche I didn't trick Mitch is my friend.
Mitch is my friend.
You can ask her.
She talked about you before.
Every time she says your name, she looks so sad.
I don't know what you did to her, but you're going to be
sorry.
Yeah, Spinelli was so cute.
What are you two doing in this cage?
Making light bulbs.
Look, we're working as hard as we can.
Why don't you leave us alone?
I'm here to help.
children i'm here to help there's really not much more room
in here your hands are too big to make light bulbs you
shouldn't be making light bulbs i'm here to help you get out
of this cage you can't do that we have to stay here and take
care of mitchie she'd be so sad here all alone sometimes we
hear her crying you know that's so sad my hands are not too
big to make light bulb how dare
I have tiny beautiful skeleton dainty hands that can make
light bulbs my hands are not too big to make light bulbs
then why don't you help I'm in the maritime Union I'm in the
maritime Union we can't do factory work I don't know what
those words mean he doesn't want to help us because he's
mean no no I'm part of the They'll revoke my membership!
My butt's too big to sit on, oh yeah.
My butt's too big to sit on one of those little perches.
Um, I'm gonna tell Mecha you said that what?
Wait, we're not allowed, we're not allowed to say butt?
Or perches.
I just don't have any of those little tiny tools, that's
all.
Here, take my hammer.
They're like the opposite of the three little...
little trick-or-treater kids from Nightmare Before
Christmas, but they're little angels.
They're like, you're not allowed to say, but.
And we also throw hammers at your face.
But you're evil, and we don't allow evil.
I didn't trick anybody.
Mr. Hurley said he was supposed to take care of Meche, but
you stole her case from him.
Is that true?
Lock, shock, and barrel.
Let me see if I can explain this whole thing to you.
You see, I had this...
selling travel packages to immigrant souls if I sold enough
of them I got to leave the land of the dead now I was in a
slump and I really needed a fat commission so you're a bad
man go away bad man yeah go wait what just because of travel
packages I'm not selling a timeshare here or anything you
bite me and I'll sue your parents yeah our parents I got an
achievement for making them cry oh god they're so loud stop
crying nice cage mr.
Harley grew demon ravens with human heads in here he said if
we ever tried to get away he'd send the ravens after us and
let them make nests out of our bones you're too little bad
little children i'm glad you're in a cage you're too bad
little children i'm glad you're in a cage very bad you guys
are so bad why are they laughing I'm the one who's gonna
take Meche out of here.
What?
I'm glad you're in the cave.
Who's gonna take care of us?
We'll be all alone.
Oh no, they're crying again.
Okay, I'm here to help you get out.
You can't do that.
We have to stay here and take care of Meche.
She'd be so sad here all alone.
Okay, now we're in a conversation.
Sometimes we hear them crying, you know.
You children just wait here and be brave little Angelitos,
okay?
okay can I have that ham oh you don't have a hammer anymore
dummy kid uh yoink I'll take that thank you what's this I
don't really want to do that uh what is it I don't really
want to do oh wait no no put it away wait what is this no no
no what is it I'm just trying to see what it is I like my
old desk better okay no drawers Okay, just kidding.
Never mind then.
Oh, this is our office!
Okay, so we...
There was some stuff over here in here that I didn't
actually get to really...
Oh, this is where Mitch is.
Oh, look, it's my prince charming.
Are you back here just to insult me some more, or do you
just want some ice for your head?
She's changed, you guys.
She's changed.
Children's books...
I like to read to the Angelitos.
It reminds me of better times.
Ice cold, yeah.
What's in here?
Sir, do you have an appointment?
I'm going in there to tell Domino my demands.
I don't think you fully understand the chain of command
around here.
Huggsy and Bebe work for you.
You and I work for Domino, who works for Hector Le Mans'
crime boss of El Maro.
Well, I think it's time for a little corporate
restructuring.
Speaking of chain smoking, madame.
Oh.
uh hello excuse me what are you staring at the slowest rays
domino domino domino taking your first coffee break already
calavera we got a score said lissy you know if i ever spoke
to my boss hector that i didn't want to get hired here you
killed my best friend you killed my best friend the demon
man you can use a demon as a driver let him carry your
messages let him serve you food he's listening to jazz ever
start thinking of them as friends it's just not natural I
can hear it how can you keep our little children in cages
how can you keep little children in a cage trust me it's
easier than keeping big kids in a cage why don't you just
let me just sprout me like you try to put us a That was
Hector.
He's so unimaginative.
Just wants to tie up the loose ends, you know?
But I believe, however, that you can be rehabilitated
through honest work.
He doesn't see me as a threat.
He doesn't see me as someone that can do this.
Yeah, what makes you think?
What makes you think I'm gonna work for you?
Well, there's not much to do on this island if you don't
work, take it for me.
And think about it.
Once I'm gone, it will be just you and Meche alone on this
deserted island.
What was I supposed to mean?
Don't tell me that prospect doesn't appeal to you.
I'm taking her.
I'm taking Mitchie out of this dungeon.
Manny, before I found her, she spent a year out there in the
petrified forest alone because of you.
Well, I mean...
By comparison, I'd say I'm keeping her pretty comfortable
here in my dungeon.
Wouldn't you say?
You know, I thought about it.
Why didn't we search for her in the forest?
We're like, oh, she'll get through it eventually.
And I'll set up my cozy restaurant here.
What?
We actually didn't, like, go and look for her.
We were just like, yeah, she'll make it through eventually.
And when she makes it through, which she definitely will,
and not end up like those bones that we had to cross on the
bridge.
You know, we will...
She'll be here.
I'll keep asking about her every day.
if I go back there?
That was scary.
I don't want to do that.
Uh...
Yeah, what are...
What are you doing out here on the edge of the world?
Oh, I know.
I ask myself that every day.
But I'm going to train you, Manny, to take my place here
running this 2-bit light bulb factory.
What is a light bulb factory?
Yeah, what...
You and Hector set up a secret hideout to make light bulbs?
Oh, no.
That's just a secret.
side benefit the real purpose is to have a place we can lock
up all those old clients of mine can't have good people
wandering loose in the land of the dead telling everybody
how we stole their double in tickets now can we you stole
their tickets all these people's tickets okay how much of
this haven't you figured out i was gonna say haven't we
didn't we already know this to me after he switched over
their tickets to a secret holy fund i'd cover up the paper
trail and we'd make and jumped overboard at the pearl you
were getting all good you were getting all the good clients
i handled them all except for mercedes who you hijacked for
me in that ridiculous hot rod which i saw by the way last
time i was in rubicaba yeah i tell you manny hot rods like
that just don't look safe to me it's fine i'm already a bag
of bones manny trying to take the forklift to go look for
her in the forest.
But he kept looking.
He's like, not here.
That was the end of it.
That is exactly actually what happened in the forest.
That is, that is, that is.
So it wasn't my fault, METI didn't get a ticket.
You stole it.
Well, it's your fault she ended up in the forest instead of
coming here right away, but I fixed that.
Yeah, one ticket for you.
Well, they're selling it to rich, fancy people that are like
I express ticket, please.
One ticket for you, one for Hector.
How many more do you need?
Oh, Manny.
We never touched the product ourselves.
The product.
We sold a ticket to unfortunate souls, unable to lead moral
lives because of the crippling amount of cash they were born
into.
You could just...
You could just take the tickets and leave today.
We found a way to make the land of the dead livable.
Why would we want to leave?
But like, what do you do here?
Like, what do you...
What do you got going on?
Hmm.
It's not my fault I was born with so much money.
When I was born, instead of a teet, I was gripping my
mother's $200 bills.
so sad so sad my my mom's a lot of cash
i don't plan to be on this island for very long manny i have
all the guns i have all the transportation and i have all
the brains
Uh, I'll get out of the octopus.
Nice island you got here.
Yeah, the previous owners didn't know what they had here.
Let us pick it up for a song.
They scooped out all the quarrel they could reach with their
crane and then abandoned the plant.
But we knew we had what it would take to go the extra
distance to the big reef.
Are you about to lecture me about the winning attitude
again?
No, slave labor, Manny.
That's the real ticket to success.
back to trying to escape.
Hey, you do that, kid.
Knock yourself out.
The, uh, the, what's it called?
The, the light, the lit up coral.
Oh, so there are light bulbs that just always stay on
because of the coral.
They're made out of the coral that lights up.
Wait, that's kind of sick.
Wait.
That's kind of awesome.
Hit him with the hammer.
Hold on.
Not yet.
think we need to talk i think we need to talk start talking
you're the salesman oh she hates us she hates us and i have
a lot i have a lot of explaining to do save your breath
domino's explained it all to me already and you're gonna
believe him come on we're getting out of here trying to
steal my commission from domino again manny don't you ever
give up i'm not after any commission yeah After any
commission, I just want to get us both out of here.
Then why don't you just ask your boss for the day off?
She's my arch nemesis!
Can't believe you think he's my boss.
He's my arch enemy.
I think he's your boss.
You think he's my boyfriend.
We don't seem to have a good foundation of trust in our
relationship, do we?
Oh, she is like...
I'm sorry I implied he was your boyfriend.
I do trust you.
Well, I'm not sure I trust you about that, but I'll tell you
when.
thing that would convince me.
Name it.
Give me your gun.
Wait, I have a gun?
Since when?
Wait, when did I get a gun?
Well, yeah, what makes you think I have a gun?
Is that a gun in your pants or are you just happy to see me?
What?
What makes you think I have a gun?
You work for the most heavily armed organization in the land
of the dead.
Don't try to tell me they didn't issue you a gun.
Oh, wait, they did all caps.
They did an issue me.
I don't work for the most heavily armed organization!
I want to know...
You have a lot of explaining to do.
Me?
About what?
Oh.
I guess I should have answered the other thing first, but...
Why are those children locked up in a cage?
With the wings those Angelitos have, they're the only things
on this island.
Domino can't control.
Why are you working for Dominic?
I do what he asks only to protect the children Okay They can
fly yeah, they can fly let's set the kids free to go get
help.
Yeah, they can't fly that far manny But they can't fly
circles around domino and they can bite.
They're always biting What were you doing?
Yeah, what were you doing that whole year?
I was in ubacava.
I was lost What did you I don't want to talk about that
year, please.
Oh, it's traumatizing for her Why did you run out of my
office?
So why did you run out of my office?
I felt so embarrassed, and you looked so disappointed in me.
I couldn't stand it anymore.
Has Domino hurt you in any way?
Not as much as I've hurt him.
Boy, can that guy take a punch.
Oh, nice.
Why did you take me out with that champagne bottle?
I told you to stop you from falling into Domino's trap.
If you had made it on that ship, then you would have ended
up...
Here?
Yes, okay, I'll lay off the questions great now something
you just lay off glitching hey I'm a sailor now.
We have to wear this stuff Also, I don't like me most I
don't work for the most heavily armed organization anywhere,
you know, you're right There are those rumors of that
revolutionary army that's been stockpiling weapons actually
them I work for Why don't you come back when you're willing
to deal straight with me?
Oh, I don't think they there's like three of us though.
There's like three of us I promise.
You think I can take him out with the mini hammer?
Sir, do you have an appointment?
I'm going in there to tell Domino my demands.
He's listening.
He can't even hear you.
I don't think you fully understand the chain of command
around.
It's really small.
Please put that.
Okay.
You can take out the tiny hammer if you want.
He's got eyes in the back of his head.
No, I don't think I could take his laughter a second time.
That's the way we walked all the way over here.
We walked all the way over here.
Okay.
You got lucky this time.
Not everyone can handle a tiny hammer.
the way I can he's just really nervous about it what's in
there it's empty our type of business doesn't produce a lot
of paperwork it's empty our type of business doesn't produce
a lot of paper okay let's see what that thing was again.
Uh-huh.
It's about how you use it.
Yeah.
There is also this way.
But this probably, I imagine, reverses it?
Yes.
My assumption was correct.
Thank you so much for 13 months!
Brokey!
Thank you.
Here we go!
Uh-oh.
What do you mean, uh-oh?
Wait, what happened?
What's going on?
What?
I can't do anything.
Oh, I'm moving?
Oh, okay, okay.
Interesting.
I'm not quite sure what's happening, but...
Gladys?
Gladys!
Oh.
You're okay.
Well, it hurt a little when I hit, but my head cracked open
an aft panel here.
I gotta tell you, Cardinal, I thought you were dead.
Oh, Manny, I've been having a great time.
Listen.
Okay.
What is that?
I ask you, is there an engine that can resist the love
that's in these ads?
Apparently not.
What is he doing?
I think this baby's our ticket out of here.
Oh yeah, good point.
I was just wrenching it for fun, but your idea is good too.
Yeah.
I think...
What?
Oh.
Oh yeah, good.
I was...
What's he doing though?
He's just, like, tinkering with stuff?
So good to see him again.
So true!
Alright, we can go back up then.
Yeah, pick up Raid from the last foes, are true.
Do we...
I think we can go up now, I wonder.
Sorry, I heard that.
I'm moving around.
Oh, uh, no, no, no, no, no.
Get off, get off.
There we go.
I mean, do we even want to go up?
I don't know.
Maybe.
It's the anchor at the end.
So I guess maybe we'll want to like...
I don't know.
I can go up.
I just have to walk up.
But maybe we...
I don't know.
Use this to...
Somehow dislodge the anchor eventually.
What's over here?
Oh, oh wow, we're fast.
What does this mean?
Oh, I'm operating this?
Oh my god.
What is this?
It's gonna grind me to bones.
I mean, it's gonna grind my bones.
They must bring the core over here to be crushed.
Either that or these are the biggest, meanest-looking
haircolors I've ever seen.
What's going on down here?
Okay.
Uh-huh.
I don't know what...
Hold on, I'm gonna save before we do anything.
anything else.
Oh, Pearl.
Does they have to go all the way around?
No, I don't understand.
I'm just trying to look at the rock.
Why won't it let me?
The edge of the world.
Oh, okay.
But not the edge I'm looking for.
Okay, okay.
Then come over here.
Sure, whatever.
Whatever, whatever.
Does holding shift make him run?
I'm actually not sure.
This group looks heavier than my last ship.
It's not a handheld device.
How am I supposed to control it, though?
Really for this side of the world, but I wanted to wish you
intended to do a happy Tanabata.
May all your wishes come true!
May all of you be happy.
Thank you, Brian.
Happy Tanabata!
Yeah!
Do you have a magic spell that makes it so I can move fast
forward in time?
Wait, fast forward time until off-the-shelf.
Kai and Densetsu concert.
I already missed AX weekend.
I have no power of that, and to be honest, I would not even
use it.
I have too much to do.
Before...
Before Densu concert.
Much too much to do.
Oh!
Yes, this is This is how we dislodge it, I guess?
I wonder if there's something we need to do first, though.
Alright, let's go check out that one other area.
Run, man, run!
Oh yeah, holding shift and the doing that does make him run
fast.
No!
Wait, where are we?
To the moon, he says.
I'll bet all these miners were brought here by that octopus.
Yeah.
Lay down your tools.
We're puffed it out of here.
Man, if I had only gotten that little steel.
Lay down your tools!
Okay.
Hello.
Chapito!
Hey!
Who?
He doesn't remember me already?
Hi!
Oh, you, this is why I ought to look at my eyebrows.
Nice drill.
Drill, this here is a cordless, high-speed reciprocating
chisel.
And look, it's a bust-all.
They usually don't give these to the new guys.
Wow, how'd you get a bust-all?
How'd you get a bust-all?
Bust-in, bust-in, bust-in, bust-in.
And I had some booty to trade.
Trade's the name of the game out here in the big reef.
I want I want to trade wait my mini my mini hammer My mini
hammer Skeleton temple of doom.
That's what I'm saying.
So this game about grim who's a fan of dango?
Oh, I'm so sorry, but the proper pronunciation is dango The
Japanese snack I want to trade something.
I want to trade something.
Well, you came to the right place sonny.
What should we need?
A hug.
A hug?
Nope, that's the one thing I ain't got for you.
Oh, that's gonna cost some.
What do you got, aren't you?
My turtleneck?
Oh, yeah, that is nice.
Acrylic?
No, it's all natural.
Oh, too bad.
Oh, no!
No, I'm so comfy.
When you got something worth trading, come see old.
chapito he'll do your right wait but my little mini hammer
where'd you get booty where'd you get booty it's all over
the ocean floor jewelry precious coins you people and your
fancy folks never know about it because you just never stop
and look never stop and appreciate the booty i'm always
appreciating the booty i think the tool looks yeah that tool
looks a little overpowered for you overpowered nothing
overpowers chapito if you say so give me some booty and i'll
give me some booty and i'll buy our way out of here yeah
yeah that works too right i traded it all for this beauty oh
you traded jewelry and precious coins for a power tool
Relax, we're busting out of here soon.
We, we are done, traveling together.
Our soul, our soul.
I walk a lonely road.
We're all gonna long day of grief reckoning, and be so.
Please, bust away.
Oh, don't say that.
I do not speak from any, or I, you know.
Maybe we can trade the tiny hammer to the...
Angel kid?
Because he threw it at me, maybe he wants it back.
But I have to trade it for him.
You know?
Here, take my hammer.
Tap tap, no backs.
Okay.
I mean, I know I got it back from, or I got it from him in
the first place, but I figured maybe they'd be like, oh man,
I can't work without my hammer.
And then I'm like, well, if you want to bag, you gotta.
Hold on, I'm gonna take it.
Let me go see if he wants the tiny hammer.
Probably not, but...
Stupid chisel.
Hold still.
Why I oughta?
Why are you oughta?
Hey, buddy.
Yo, Bito.
Have you ever seen an authentic little chipper?
A little chipper?
No, I have.
But I'd sure love to give it a test drive.
Wait, maybe this works.
Say, a little chipper, you're okay.
Yoink!
What do I do with this now?
So boaters don't see the booty because boaters don't look
down.
Winto sees all the booty.
Not a boater.
The booty.
It's a bust all.
Can I let the kids out?
Bust all.
We're busting these kids out of the cage!
Right?
Probably.
Maybe.
The bust all?
Hello, children.
We want you to go bite the guy.
That's a little bit of overkill, considering it's not
locked.
Wait, it's not locked?
Just open it up, then.
Fly, be free!
Go buy Domino!
Leave us alone!
If we get out again, he'll hurt Meche.
Oh.
Fine then.
Stay in there.
He is.
It's not even locked!
They called me mean, even though I tried to free them.
It's solving puzzles that don't exist.
It's not even locked!
Hello, I'm back.
Hey, I bought that gun.
Ready to hand over your heater?
I would if I had one.
Right.
What if I...
They didn't issue me a gun.
What, are you on probation?
I'm not buying this, Manuel.
Manny, why don't you come back when you're willing to deal
straight with me, okay?
Does the bus stall work as a gun?
she wouldn't know the difference right couples counseling
first wait what can i use it on that thing i don't want to
bust all that sir do you have an appointment i'm i hope you
oh please put that away thank you maybe we have to get his
gun somehow
you know he seems completely unaware of how close I am to
escape let me say that out loud I wonder if we can use it
wait how do I get out of here
oh wait I'm going Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, I did
the wrong thing.
Manny, talking isn't helping right now, okay?
Okay, bye.
Why does Amitje have such thick legs?
She's thick-boned.
When somebody says, I'm not fat, I've just got big bones.
Now you understand.
This is revealing everybody's nature.
Okay.
Actually, I wonder if we can use it on that rock and maybe
the rock will like, I don't know, like do something to like,
you know, like fall into the water and help it, help the
crane or I don't know, I'm grasping at straws a little bit
here, but yeah, launch it, something like that.
Not quite sure.
You gotta grasp at straws for point and clicks, right?
You really do, though.
We only have two items.
One of them's my side, so it's kind of tricky.
I don't want to bust all that.
Why not?
Okay, holding down shift after doing an item does make him
run, which is really awesome.
I can...
See why they don't give these chisels to the new guys.
The scoops learned its lesson.
I don't want to bust all that.
Um, okay.
Where are we supposed to do that?
Probably?
I did something.
Wait, that was what we were supposed to do, right?
Wait, what about the chain?
Uh-oh.
Okay.
Okay, I can't use any items here or anything either.
Let's see if Glottis needs any.
Maybe when all the stuff fell, Glottis got something.
Let's see.
Oh, it is going up.
You were so right.
One second, though.
Doesn't seem like it.
Okay, yeah.
Yeah, I almost had it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, we're fine.
I just wanted to double check.
It's so slow, though.
Okay.
I need you to run here, Manny.
Swim fast.
I know you have, like, all this water and air going through
your bones, but you just gotta make it work.
Ever!
Thank you so much for the super chat!
Watch tomorrow in time for part four.
Thank you!
Okay.
I hear it.
It's still going.
It's gone.
Wait, huh?
I mean, uh, I hate this part so slow.
Maybe I pull the thing back up instead, so we'll try that.
When I was a kid, I got stuck here because I was scared to
go over the ledge.
Oh, no!
Wait, so you never knew that glottis!
Wait, but if I do that...
Wait, if I do this, will the chain go back up?
We'll see.
Yeah, I can't.
does or wait it's all bunched up now okay wait but that
won't help me I think right but no it should actually wait
no it probably will destroy this thing I think probably
it'll destroy this and that will make the the anchor free
right wait i want to exit real quick and save just in case i
don't know i don't think it'll let me do something before
like you know what i mean like i don't think it'll let me do
something where it'll soft block me but
show my tail
wait what is this
you'd be a surprised this game is designed to not soft lock
you except the bugs can okay okay oh no no I moved to a new
location why is it the same thing you
were almost there with the lever strat dang really
oh I see why okay I thought it was going the opposite way
because like from from that angle it almost like you can it
looks like it's going down you know it it was like an
optical it's I could see it going up now but it was like an
optical illusion for me where it looked like it was going
down instead of going up that's why I was confused why the
chain wasn't going down yeah that's how then we came here
but I didn't even think about it because I already saw it
from the other angle and I was like why isn't it going down
I see it going up now.
Not yet.
I mean, yeah.
Okay.
So then if I do this again...
And it all bunches up there.
What happens if I go back?
Do you hear Yanni or do you hear Laurel?
I'm not sure what to do here.
Okay.
I
tried pulling up the chain and nothing happened.
If this is the right strategy, reverse again like this.
Oh, like that!
Oh no.
We did it!
How is this thing so strong?
To pull up...
I can't believe you got it to flow.
That was the easy part.
The trick's gonna be bustin' through that big coral reef out
there.
Bust through a big coral reef, eh?
Okay, give me a minute or two.
Yeah, I'll give me a minute.
That's it.
That's all I need.
Yeah, baby!
Gladys looks so proud.
You should be proud.
Can we run?
Can we, like...
Man, was that ever hard to launch?
I'm gonna pick it up.
Oh, that's true.
Okay, okay.
Nobody heard it either.
Think of a way to get through that reef yet?
No.
Did you?
Where does this lead us to?
Okay, okay, okay.
There's gotta be...
something going on with this thing too.
Tuna, welcome back.
Thank you so much for that, boys!
Yeah, we got our ticket out of here.
Let's go talk to...
Uh...
Wait.
Let's go talk to Meche.
Oh, wait.
I guess I'm going to need to go up that.
Dude, it's so fast.
It's like...
You would think for a game like this, it would be very
like...
You know, like very...
To get it over there, like kind of like a realistic...
A realistic scale, but no.
Just...
We could try dropping the chain down.
Oh!
But...
Oh yeah, this will do just fine.
Just give me a sec to do some figurative.
Are you...
I thought we would go inside there, but no.
We just broke the entire...
We just broke the entire thing.
Oh, wait.
Yeah,
man, he really only needed a minute for real.
That's crazy work.
What if I fall down the edge now?
though.
Shall we test it?
My partner is watching your stream for the first time.
They really grim-pandangle.
Thanks for watching!
Hi, Willys!
Hello, thank you for so much joining!
To the depths.
To the depths, to the depths, to the depths, depths, depths,
depths.
Oh, I won't let you go.
Alright.
I figured it would probably be something like that, but what
if he just kept going?
I mean, it's not strong of a current.
Well, now we don't have to go on this anymore.
That's kind of a relief.
Not gonna lie.
Give me off.
Give me off this wild run.
I went off Mr. Bones's wild run.
We go talk to Michi.
Michi, I have a boat.
I have a boat.
Listen to me.
It's big.
It's a big guy.
I don't think she'll...
I'll see if she will talk to us without the gun though.
Ready to hand over your heater?
I would if I had to.
Right.
Manny, talking isn't helping right now, okay?
What if we smoke together?
A couple that smokes together smokes together.
Interact with the ashtray.
What ashtray?
Man, that ashtray is so fancy you could eat caviar out of
it.
Once you got used to the sooty aftertaste, you'd feel like a
king.
I only steal ashtrays from bars from bars oh
oh my stockings they're ruined
awuuga you try to have one nice thing on this cruel island
you
Oh, wow, he just blew our...
Sometimes I think she's a ghost because she stands.
Okay, how, guys, do we get this gun?
He just drops it on the ground.
How do we get this gun?
So, do you have an appointment?
I have you.
trade for it
he seems completely unaware of how close i am to escape why
keep looking in here i looked in here before though what the
good enough for me what is oh uh the um the speed at which
you're working that's nice manny but you're not my boss
really i couldn't care less good excellent carry on wait i
looked in there earlier he said it was empty wait what just
what did i pick up Oh, you know a little clear nail polish
would fix these right up
I would never wear these they have a hole in them
Is somebody wanting to trade this for something you think I
so do you have a puppy what if I what if I give it to domino
Domino, domino, domino, domino, domino showing bone on
stream.
I don't know.
Nah, these calves are way too boxy.
We gotta get some clear nail polish?
Actually, I've done that before though.
Where I fix stockings with clear nail polish.
But they get a little hard.
Like that spot and it kind of scratches you so you have to
be careful.
This creepy room is so funny.
Hey, kids, you got any nail polish?
Hola, Angelitos.
Hello, Mr. Mean Boss Guy.
Hey, would one of you children happen to have a gun?
Yeah, we do.
So stick him up.
Let me see it.
He doesn't have one.
He's such a liar.
Oh, yeah, well, you're stupid.
Your light bulbs don't work.
Your light bulbs all smell like boogers.
anymore oh yeah well everybody in this cage is smarter than
you everybody except for you yeah because i'm especially
smarter than you in your dreams in your baby bed that's all
wet could you wet in it shut up bed wetter i said shut up no
no really i have to sleep with an umbrella down here oh yeah
well at least i never asked mech to marry me what miss
colomar you're so pretty Will you marry me?
I never said that!
Oh, Miss Colomar!
Stupid baby blue beanie bedwetter!
Pugsy the Bugsy lies like a rugsy!
Will you two just shut up?
Okay.
Time for the yellow super chat again.
No, it's not!
Wait, are they still crying, you think?
Oh, they're fine.
They're fine.
What do they think of?
This.
Does this mean anything to you?
I'm sorry, kids.
But these stockings are all that's left of our poor mansion.
What?
Oh my god, he's having a panic attack.
It wasn't funny.
I'm hoping that he would say something like that.
One second, guys.
I'm gonna go get some more water real quick.
I'll be right back.
Man, he's such a troll.
Sorry!
Whoopsie!
I was muted.
Whoopsie-poopsie!
And Draco, thank you!
Just chain smoking away.
I went to get water and then I...
You ever stand up and realize you also have to go to the
little ghosty's room.
He was silent, Minto.
What is your wisdom?
Okay, let's figure out how to fix these stockings.
I think what I could do is... Wait.
It's a bus doll.
Let's go back downstairs.
name is the only thing I haven't checked but um I was like
what if I put the stocking over the the bus stall and it
looks like a gun but how can I combine you can't really like
combining items and this is not really a thing just be a
little chipper hello chapido quit yelling oh yes How do you
get a bus stop?
How do you get a bus stop?
I'm connected.
Plugged in.
And I had to- July 9th, I'll turn.
23!
Wow, soon!
Soon, soon, soon!
Happy early birthday!
Wait, let's try the-
Let's try taking it out.
Maybe he'll want it.
This is so messed up though.
Check out the hosiery.
Hey, these are real silk.
Where'd you find them?
I've been wearing them the whole time.
You two?
Well, then, here's your new best friend.
Ah, my first Sproutella gun.
Is it loaded?
Wait, what?
Hey, bullets are hard to get.
Why did he give me a gun for having...
Wait, what?
Jo-de-do.
What?
Wait, what?
It's really not much use without bullets.
Ah, my first Sproutella gun.
Did I trade my stockings?
Honestly, not worth.
But we have to continue the story.
Hi, Tesco!
Hi, my wife!
Hello!
Let's save and then we're gonna use it on everybody
Hands up Too easy
Sir do you have enough Please put that away Don't thank you.
Don't just listen to him, Manny.
Okay, anyway
Here what good's a relationship without trust true a
relationship without trust is about as empty as a gun
without bullets Guess you didn't realize a smart girl always
keeps an extra round in her hat for mad days.
Come on.
Let's go.
Mitchie You don't know what you're I know exactly what I'm
doing now.
Move Would you just listen to my escape plan first trouble
in paradise?
kids you're letting us go right now or your boy Friday here
gets it well I hate to see you go manny but the lady seems
to have made up her mind I'm serious I'll shoot him fine he
really doesn't work for me anyway but I thought I'll shoot
you then no you won't you're too good remember I'm not I'm
not good anymore you've taken that out of me keeping me a
prisoner here I'm gonna crack you open like a fake big boss
I'm gonna why did we just stand there and not do Why didn't
we do anything?
She's a firecracker, but a night in the cooler usually
dampens her fuse.
Why didn't we do anything?
Manny!
Where did we...
Where did we... Where did she go?
He keeps looking at it, so funny.
It's empty.
Yeah, now it is.
Open this door.
Oh, in here.
No.
Bebe?
Oh, geez.
Is there anybody out there?
I...
I think a betcha might be stupid.
Domino, you'd better let me out of here.
Wait, is this an actual lock?
Lefty Lucy?
Right, that's gotta be it, too, right?
Lefty Lucy.
You're right, you're right.
I'm in here!
Domino, you'd better let me out of here!
I...
Hey!
Oh gosh.
So, you know, in school, you would have lockers with locks
like that.
Not me.
I don't know how to open them.
I once had a mailbox that had one of those types of locks.
like the you go over this one time and then this time or
whatever whatever yeah combination lock i didn't check my
mail for for like six months because i couldn't open it and
i was too shy i was too nervous anxious to ask the front the
like the person watching over the dormitory for help so
yeah where he showed his game collection.
One of his games was Ace Combat 6.
Let's go!
David Hater knows ball.
Help me.
She's locked in there.
Hola, Angelitos.
Hello, Mr. Mean Boss Guy.
New plan.
Me just locked up for good.
We're leaving without...
No, that's not what we were trying to do!
There's the kid hyperventilating that early.
How am I supposed to know?
Maybe it makes it like a sound.
Maybe it's an audio thing.
I'm getting angry.
Must be a combination lock, but there are no numbers on it.
This isn't funny.
I just wish she'd shut up.
Manny, where are you?
So she shuts up.
I'm sorry I didn't trust you.
Whoa, that sounded like different.
It's me!
Meche!
Open this door!
Did that sound different?
This isn't funny!
Penny, thank you for the raid!
Hello everybody!
Hello!
Wait.
Open this door!
Shut up!
I'm going to become the Joker.
Is there anybody out there?
I'm in here!
Manny!
Open this door!
Oh my god.
Stay in there for eternity!
I don't care!
Hey, where are you?
Oh my god!
Thank you guys for all the...
Gifted!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Manny!
Say something!
Knock on the door, say, Meche!
It's me!
I'm right outside!
Maybe it's in here, right?
be like I've what the it's locked what what what locked wait
what that's not what I clicked on wait wait I clicked on
this it's locked huh thank you guys so much for all the look
at that thank you children's books it's locked time
to baby but how do i use it like rather okay let's try if i
do this i don't want to bust all that why not there could be
a clue in there there could be a clue you have everything
you need to open that door i do well i guess i only have two
things to open the door i
don't want to mess up my blade
Do I actually have everything to open up this door?
I sure don't think so.
I only steal ashtrays from bars.
The different door.
Manny!
yes I don't want to mess up the wheel the wheels my friend
if I bust all the handle then I'm never gonna get in there
baby can I just open the handle I guess I didn't enter the
right I'm sorry I didn't trust you out of air oh my god shut
up the wheel is my friend how am I supposed to know I'm
warning you domino I'm
How am I supposed to know?
Yeah, just turn off the voice for real.
It's actually so annoying.
Okay, she's much quieter now.
What if I could bust it?
What if I busted?
Okay.
There we go, there we go.
No, you're not!
I think I'm running out of air!
Shut up, lady!
The door is open!
Are we being for real?
Wait, okay, let me turn the sound back up now.
I can't move those by hand.
I need this wheel.
Wait, what?
What do you mean I need the wheel?
There we go.
Oh, like this.
Oh, interesting.
Wait, what does it look like unlocked?
Like, what shape is it supposed to be?
You know?
I can't tell.
Oh, I see.
Like, that?
Okay.
Yeah, aligned with the edge makes the most.
Okay, I get- I understand it, I understand it.
Wait.
Like that, like that, okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, okay, okay, okay.
Is that good enough?
Maybe?
It's kind of hard to tell.
Oh, why did I get both of them?
No!
Aw, man.
I messed it up.
Oh, I messed it up.
Might be more fluid with a keyboard.
Oh, maybe, yeah.
I don't want it to move, though.
How many... I wasn't counting.
I wasn't... I wasn't counting, so I don't know if the top
one will move.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Ah, ah.
Is that enough?
No!
Oh, did I just have it?
That might be enough.
Maybe that's enough.
Oh, wait.
What?
Oh, and I had them so nicely lined up and everything.
Why?
why i can't move those by hand i need this wheel
no way that's so screwed up that's so screwed up
you solved half the puzzle oh yippie yippie for that i guess
maybe yeah we have to block them or something to from
This doesn't, they don't look lined up at all actually.
I think I messed up.
There's dang half things of cheese.
What?
Okay.
This is good enough, right?
No, no.
Like that maybe?
Hold on.
I'm gonna save real quick.
Click.
What?
Oh, this union card is what he was talking about.
That go in there?
Okay.
Ooh, I hate that sound.
Yeah, that was terrible.
Wait, did I not?
Did I not go in?
Ooh, I hate that sound.
not enough of a gap maybe yeah let's try it it looked so
much oh my gosh shut up you you
uh i think the bottom ones weren't quite aligned
oh that one's perfect now
oh you moved there we go there we go maybe There we go,
there we go, maybe.
They looked so much more lined up the first time I did it
correctly.
So it's kind of like weird.
Stay.
Stay?
Okay.
Oh, sorry, I'm saving again.
Yes!
At least she shut up.
No rush at all.
Mitchie you can come out now is she is she even still in
here that's what that's why she shut up because she's not
even in here anymore oh Mitchie no electrical current makes
my marrow tingle she could be in any one of these
i'll just take that
We have no muscle!
We are all bone!
We have no muscle.
Man, people in the old days were huge.
Doesn't look like he'd enjoy a piggyback ride.
Is she in there?
Michi, are you in there?
It's time to come out, honey.
No time for hide and seek.
Um...
Looks like years and years of time.
coral harvest reports this can't be what this secret safe is
meant to hold uh-huh
looks like years and years they're all locked up these must
be very they're all locked up they're all locked up how can
you you checked every single one you opened them all with
your hands yeah they are they're actually they're all locked
up you checked you you you have you verified this yourself
manny
Let's try this again.
An urm source?
What?
Wait.
Oh.
I want to...
Oh, okay.
Let's try and get grab...
Make it fall on her toes.
Wait, can you grab it now?
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Wait, can you grab it?
Oh, okay.
Grab it.
Okay.
Okay, maybe like that.
No?
I thought she'd be like, ouch!
I thought she'd be like, ouch, ouch.
That just fell on my toes.
How do you know it's not her?
Where else did she go?
Gamers don't look up.
Doesn't look like he didn't Enjoy a piggyback ride.
Mitchie, are you in there?
It's time to come out, honey.
No time for hide and seek.
No, electrical current makes my marrow tingle.
What if, um, what if it's like a, it's like a wait thing on
the middle of this thing?
Anything on the other side of the room It wasn't...
It wasn't letting me look.
Yeah.
Let's look.
Oh, there's nothing on this side of the room.
I mean, I could try doing something with this.
Ah!
Big wind-up attack!
Uh-oh.
Oh, Raul.
I am so, so sorry.
Oh!
Wait.
I don't think it's gonna be as easy to pick from this side.
guys no electrical current makes my marrow tingle no
it's fine we can we can bust anything we can bust it I
already did that from the other side no no we can bust this
thing too I think that we just bring the whole ugly thing
crashing down on me oh he's gonna choose one to bust off
screen bust all my ass oh so
it must be one of these I feel like it's a pressure point in
the middle you know I don't want to bust all that or
something to like open up a secret passage maybe
not Thanks for being my gym buddy again today.
Minto, your streams are always so great for keeping me
company, keeping me motivated.
Superliminal!
Good job working out!
Good job!
As a former clarinet player, I like this music.
Oh, everybody, we got a squid word here in the chat.
As a former clarinet player.
Sorry.
I was a former flute player.
so we're little enemies a little bit well not enemies but
you know hmm can't get in there with this did you guys ever
have like orchestra versus band like though there was like
band geeks and then the orcadorks I was both I was both so I
I always got picked on.
Squillium enchant.
Orchidorks.
Yeah, that's what they called everybody in orchestra.
We're like, oh no, here's the orchidorks to...
I don't want to ruin my size.
You want a piece of calavera suit?
Suit?
Hmm, you can't get in there with this.
Eh!
Maybe this.
What, instruments?
I played flute.
Oh!
Manny, I knew you would- Why is that door closed?
It was the only way I, uh, the wind.
Oh.
I played a flute and I played a violin.
...
Wait, what if it was open, though?
I feel like it...
Hey, this is my room.
Go use up the air in your own room.
I feel like...
We had to shut it for some reason, you know?
Warning.
Fire system.
Do not touch.
Nothing.
I can't reach that high.
Thanks for not shooting me.
Look.
I'm sorry.
I should have trusted you.
It's just that the past two years have been pretty tough,
you know?
Imete, I'm sorry You look like you could use a nice ocean
cruise still my travel agent, eh?
What's in here?
What's in these cases take a look?
Stockings it's all the double end tickets Hector and Dama
stolen over the years each one stolen from a good soul And
now they just sit there.
What?
They just sit here?
They just sit there.
That's what's been bothering me in the days when I was a hot
salesman I used to see double-end tickets all the time and
they move.
What do you mean they move?
They become agitated around human souls and the ticket that
belongs to you will actually fly into your hand But these
tickets and the tickets in that suitcase of Charlie's it's
like they're dead Why would Hector and Domino be hoarding
cases of counterfeit double-end tickets?
Oh
requesting locomotive breath for next karaoke I don't know
how to well I think I remember I don't know I don't remember
how to play the flute but I definitely remember the flute
lips
I remember that real fake tickets
up there that vent is the only way out of here that i can
see can we move these or climb on top of that guy
why would hector and domino be hoarding cases of counterfeit
double-in tickets why would hector and domino be hoarding
cases of counterfeit double-in tickets
um oh oh i thought my game crashed for a second that one is
a different colorish maybe Maybe?
Maybe?
Did she see that?
That's kind of embarrassing.
You look like you...
Still my travel agent, eh?
And nothing happens.
I can't reach that high.
You look like you could use...
Still my travel agent, eh?
What else we have?
You.
On this.
I don't want to bust all that.
Why not?
I think we should.
What do we use this axe for?
I don't want to bust all that.
You're so close?
I am?
Wait, in what regard?
Hmm.
Axe is important.
Yeah, I figure because we haven't used it yet for the
puzzle, but it's here.
Mitzi with the axe.
I'll get her toes.
Like my previous plan.
Oh, won't even let me get her toes.
This one's also a different color.
No.
Oh, you guys can barely see it.
Sorry.
You can see it more there.
I'm like, is that this one?
I was like, is this a raised platform?
I can't get close to much stuff though.
Have we resorted to action?
throwing we've resorted to axe dragging would you like a
hint yeah a small small hint small small hint since I'm I've
tried a couple different things now small small hint
what's in your pocket like this guy because he's tall and
can reach oh he is tall and can reach no he's not no oh he
can do is wait for the room to fill up and we'll just float
on out of here wait what that's your idea well this is
disappointing not to me we don't float remember
I don't want to mess up my blade.
Well, that was really cool and awesome.
Thank you.
Oh, not again.
We have water.
And that should do something.
the axe is still just as heavy as before is there I see if
there's like stuff reflected now like the room is a little
bit reflected but I don't think there's anything that
changed or rather I don't see anything that like reflects
that oh yeah where is the drain right
pay attention where the water drains.
That makes no sense.
There is no drain.
It blacks out.
No?
Why would Hector and Domino be hoarding cases of counterfeit
double-in tickets?
Maybe we can...
Oh, here?
Into this mysterious... Maybe we block it up with the axe?
Huh?
Okay.
That should be good, right?
Oh, it did drain there.
After you.
What about the suitcases?
Forget them.
They're counterfeit.
They wouldn't fit through this hole anyway.
Let's go.
Counterfeits don't fit through holes.
Galatas, I'm so glad to see you.
Oh, my God!
Is the boat already?
Yeah, come on!
Let's go eat some reef!
That's it?
Works like crazy!
Full speed ahead!
Wait.
What?
See ya, sucker!
So are you really going to bring me back and try to get your
own job again?
There's no job for me now, except to bring you and everyone
else here to the end of the road.
But if you aren't going to use me to get your job back, why
did you spend all this time trying to find me?
Meche, I...
Wait, what's in the water?
Turn around?
I needed to find you.
No!
Octopus!
I give you one job, Manny!
at you already screwing it up.
Go punch him in the face.
Oh, Scythe Fight!
Scythe Fight!
I suppose you realize that this is gonna go down on your
permanent record.
Oh, oh, me too.
Oh, I only have this.
Scythe Fight!
Oh, yeah, I'm gonna save real quick.
Stand in here.
realize
first of all let's take care of that guy I don't believe you
Calavera yeah you're losing a fight so you pick on one of my
pets why aren't you more like me Manny I've been trying to
show you how but you don't listen if you just adopt the
proper attitude just look what could happen to you Oh my
god!
Oh my god!
If you let him grapple you...
Oh, I just...
Get
it!
Oh wow!
We escaped with everybody, I guess?
We look so tired and defeated.
Are we okay?
Okay.
I do wanna see though.
Skelly on the decoration.
Name.
Pugsy Peligiano, sir.
Waiting room number two.
Next.
Pugsy.
Ah!
Glottis?
Gloris!
Gloris?
Where'd you go this time?
Okie dokie!
That was a strange conclusion there!
Is that good?
Gloris just fell.
Did he have, like, a sickness?
altitude sickness another cliffhanger I know my goodness
where are we now what's in our inventory now our old
faithful hold on I want to load and see what happens if you
attack him oh that's it this doesn't look good for the kid
look Dom, I'm not gonna work for you.
Oh, don't worry about that.
You're fired.
Just consider this.
Your severance.
Oh, that's a good show.
Whoa!
Let's keep going.
Let's keep trying it.
Yeah, we get...
I want the voice lines on set.
I'm sending this domino back to the bone pile.
Ah!
Smart strategy, always let your boss win.
You know, your name is Domino, but you're really just a
pawn.
Please, save the comic book one-liners when you're winning.
I mean, I did win.
We watched you get crushed, man.
I want to see if we can do anything else, like if we can run
out.
I don't think my bare hands would be a match with that sight
to his.
I don't know any wrestling moves.
Oh, come on, man.
Domino's just the kind of guy to practice oxford regulation
boxing, the fight well that's fine we we were able to take
him down no cqc this time no cqc this time manny manny is
too stupid i guess oh wow so next time wow that was way
faster than last chapter but next next chapter year four and
um, we'll beat the game!
Ooh!
Shouting.
Shouting, just look what could happen to you over the roar
of the grinder that's about to destroy you is a cool way for
a guy as full of himself as Domino to go out.
Lives in my head forever.
It was so awesome!
Just look what could happen to you!
Crunch, crunch, crunch, crunch, crunch, crunch, crunch.
naps and crackles and pups.
It's so good.
Yeah!
This one was fun.
I'm glad we got to see Mitje again.
Wait a second.
I think the side borders are changing.
This is very like Aztec now.
It's cool.
But this is fine.
This is fine.
I'm excited to see how the game ends.
Yeah, it's a little different now.
I think it was a little different now.
I think was different this is different from last chapter
neat i didn't realize if they changed each year this one is
so dramatically different though that i noticed it yeah i
noticed the temple too right and the guy up here hey oh
where is everybody waiting area two how long do they have to
wait in there until they have tickets they were issued
tickets on the number nine and they don't have them now the
punishment for selling double end tickets is very severe but
they didn't sell their tickets their tickets were stolen
yeah by who hector leman stole them to sell to rich people
who don't deserve them that might be them now let's see just
what they deserve
oh wait I didn't want to save this or I wanted to save this
until next time but Oh!
Yeah!
What?
Oh my god!
So all these people are paying for their tickets.
Not even realizing that they're just going straight down
anyway.
Whoa!
They don't even know.
Oh yeah, this is literally what my daily commute feels like.
That rush hour, am I right?
That rush hour traffic.
They have no idea.
Yeah, they're getting double-crossed.
Yeah, they're paying.
Dang.
Wait, that's crazy.
Oh gosh.
Okay, I can't wait to see how we conclude this.
Which will be later in a few days.
days.
If you're watching the VOD, might already be up.
Yeah, awesome, awesome, awesome.
This was a great, oh, this was a really fun one.
I liked this one, so, fatality again.
What a hook for the next chapter.
I know I'm so excited.
Thank you guys so much for watching again today.
Dargo, thank you.
We'll find out the rest of what happens next year in a
couple of days.
Have a great night.
are feeling better thank you um getting there i hope make me
thank you thank you so much you guys for the super chats we
really really appreciate it we appreciate it so so much um
especially the pink thank you yippee yippee yippee yippee
okay then we'll continue this next time last chapter and
yeah oh it's a meet everybody it's a It's a beetle!
I'm gonna, since this ended a little bit early, I can do
some further...
Hi, dog!
Would you blame me if I sent the weird nervous panty guy
from Denton to meet greet from Friday?
Wait!
Sorry for any social faux pas.
I'm misspeaking.
No!
What the heck's all time?
You should have said something!
pleasure to meet you three.
Yes, I was at the jazz panel.
Congrats to you and Phoebe.
Oh, thank you so much.
Well, it's funny.
You probably were just not expecting to see that at the
panel then.
The announcement.
But, um, what was I going to say?
Yeah, because we were ending a little bit early, I have some
things that I wanted to set up.
I'm still slowly but surely finishing up my unpacking.
Oh gosh, I'm so used to saying packing that.
Now it's weird to say unpacking.
Thank
you so much.
Have a good day.
Have a good night.
Let's see if anybody is streaming.
Oh, wait.
I think actually...
I don't see anybody.
I was going to see if Phoebe or Vicky, but...
I think...
they're traveling.
So...
That's okay.
Anyway.
What's up, everybody?
Bye-bye.
Oh, bye-bye, bye-bye.
Bye bye, bye bye
Do you guys like the lizards?
It's the lizards everybody drew for me!
Many many lizards.
Many many lizards!
Yeah!
Thanks for all the lizard art.
Thank you everybody.
They're so cute.
Thank you!